so as the number of vaccinations being
administered is going down
unfortunately hospitalizations are going
up
and doctors are bracing for more
victoria saha takes a closer look at who
is being hospitalized more than a month
ago we heard the words if you are
vaccinated you can take off your mask
if not wear it as restrictions eased
masks came off vaccinated or not now
copin 19 cases are growing again dr mark
gesher an er doctor at summerlin
hospital tells me a good part of his day
has been treating those with kovitz
in the first few hours of my shift i saw
approximately six coped patients all
known kovit
the youngest was probably in the 20s his
team is preparing for a surge
similar to last year there are patients
that are going up to
in the hospital that are being put on
high flow oxygen and we're starting with
some of the protocols that we used last
year
dr jesser says these patients have one
thing in common
they are unvaccinated cova 19
hospitalizations are increasing not only
in las vegas but throughout the state
the most recent numbers from the nevada
health response says as of wednesday
there were 557 confirmed
hospitalizations
whereas last year this time there was
six hundred and seven
that's not much of a big difference we
have three
good vaccines available with us
that is the productive ship which we did
not have last year
dr manas mandel says there may not be an
end in sight for the pandemic if the low
interest in the vaccine the infection
once again developing victoria saha 8
news now
we can also tell you that victoria
reached out to sunrise hospital and they
tell us
they do have coveted patients on
ventilators
and say about 80 percent of those cobit
patients
are not vaccinated